hello everyone and welcome back to house
of horrors I'm zareen I'm Jeff playin
lucious the game's orange picked I don't
understand we like a demon outside yeah
I think you should tell me where the
lucious is dad so this little boy is
creepy creepy boy is the son of Satan
yeah better I promise it's exactly like
the omen if you caught that movie so the
premise of the game is you play this
little demon boy and this gets very
disturbing yeah who murders the people
in his household if he does not like
them and he doesn't like anybody yep and
he also doesn't have any more
expressions than this expression he's
like Keanu Reeves hey I love Canada
Reeves hey so we got skills this
detection there's a stealth mechanic in
the game which is it's all right I found
it ok so far yeah I mean it's we found
it similar to Skyrim stealth where you
can just stand behind somebody and they
don't see you anymore jeez Mary she
doesn't want us to lock her in at all
it's like murders already that's like
the main game mechanic uh-oh r.i.p Mary
Mary's frozen to death I should get the
padlock so no one will suspect it with
me that's right how much powers yeah so
these are so you can help kill more
people later things are a mess she's got
a real negative repercussions in an
election make sure so inconvenient when
people die and you have there you go
there's a clean up my room cleaned up my
broom so throughout the game you get
like little chores you can do to improve
your behavior yes so I'm pretty sure
it's so they don't suspect you of
anything basically so you can keep
murdering people you have to clean your
room yeah i mean like good boys do yeah
and also I can't stand crucifixes
because they damage me yeah so you can
see that little lever thing on the left
hand side goes down see it's so easy to
stand one like would you go the death
scenes are really man like God oh don't
do that Oh God oh he's faced like just
when there weren't any murders there was
another murder I mean accident it was
too oh my god spatial-awareness you
hotter than look yeah oh i just sold the
back of my brain Oh evil so the reason
why Lucius doesn't like this guy is
because he's always drunk on the job
Lucius is not a fan of alcohol
interesting that it's fan of murder is a
better murder Oh with such a little
[ __ ] loosing our bolts from the piano
legs and petals what now get up you
idiot you have to come died here we go
good you
oh that's so brutal ohashi and dirty
everything is just really just come away
hey the music gets really like
unnecessarily epic as well it done
didn't between killing people you also
do chores to earn goody points brownie
points such as moving boxes he's also
really good at holding something with
two hands and opening doors at the same
time please II would see it's moving my
dear event but wait you bought what's
going out be haha hey man we missed it I
think it just said be it just said bi
before that it was moving ib ib hip hip
hip if our next victim haha mm god I
didn't know how we thinking oh my god oh
my god oh oh dude oh dude that's crazy
it wasn't a pretty sight hey DeSean and
had blood yes we saw it these freak
accidents were keeping me out of the
night to restore it or much all the
parañaque uh she's not gonna last long
yes before Thanksgiving I'd like to see
her getting up off that horse and try it
can you please look somewhere else oh my
god someone's underwear oh my god i can
pick it up Oh what put that way bad
lishus yes it's the one on the left oh
yeah oh wait no right left left left
right left oh my house bars vine oh my
god yeah oh yes we got another present
oh what's that that's on you that's how
surprised it's not a surprise anymore
I'm ruined yeah you went to sleep so you
can wake up in the middle of the night
make sense I hate sneaking around like
it makes me really tense I love it oh
[ __ ] where was she tonight we can't even
crouched there ya know what is she like
mom what's you know any good don't run
back dirt Oh what I'm here we're already
in a locked house why all the doors lock
your mouth do you have a lock on your
bedroom door what happened us all right
oh I think you used to whoops tent uh
that's my really creepy question um I
look at her II mean I live in this
bedroom no I don't I don't either i
think when i was 15 i really wanted one
no reason so i was like a new more
privacy moment did hi to the cover just
I'd want to cover it okay I'm just stuck
in the cupboard for the rest of the game
it's like how
and that statue and thing is really
creepy why would you put that in you
okay well crap stable yet oh damn it no
enemy your mom still seems to be awake
don't let her see you nice serene be
clubbin who will come out alive yeah
let's go she should have gone down she's
fast Oh suck lies whoo now everybody
move it matters to do he's such a will
dress little boy yeah he's rich pity
he's such an [ __ ] sorry I'm just mama
earrings give me my thing well what's
going on did I get new powers what
happened oh dammit i use the thing I i
thought those are the earrings so did i
know i know i'm i think if you've only
got three lines for your people maybe
don't have him speak every two minutes
Oh complain that's a valid question it's
for me to decide who is capable of what
the way I know we've had our
difficulties this year I don't let that
difficulties 50 guys we think maybe
we'll show the Christmas lights oh yes
right he wanted to talk to all the
Christmas lives
good oh ah can we get help Lucius quick
this is terrible oh the icicle no cover
your eyes cube oh my goodness oh here we
go oh [ __ ] oh how obvious is that yeah
this happened in Grey's Anatomy well not
exactly this it was ok anatomy was a a
nice cool way through someone's chest oh
that was unexpected ok gonna can defy
find you anywhere no kid oh you got it
looks like thanks for watching we'll be
back alive next week but if you have any
comments you can leave them down below
whether you're on YouTube or games but
and leave suggestions what you want to
see us play this was a suggestion so if
you liked it or not you can go make
another suggestion something else yes
that's right thank you everybody thanks
guys